when a person's sitting in a meditation  and they're doing absolutely nothing  and it's eight o'clock in the morning  and their body for the last 10 years has  been going in traffic and getting angry  and frustrated in traffic and now  they're sitting in a meditation at eight  o'clock in the morning the body's going  to say hey you're off schedule I'm used  to suffering and getting angry here so  the body's gonna start looking for that  emotion and it's going to start  influencing the mind and you're going to  start getting images and and memories  just so you could feel that emotion like  now now the person's back in the past  but if they become aware  that they're siphoning energy out of the  present moment into the past and they  settle the body back down into the  present moment that's a victory